lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
tratar de averiguar qué tipo de reacción
se daría con todas estas moléculas que
hay aquí tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 carbonos en
un ciclo con un bromo entonces esta
molécula es bromo ciclo pentano pero no
ciclo
venta no
para no crear y tenemos bromo ciclo
pantano y como solvente tenemos dimetil
formamida tmf
ya tengo dibujada aquí la molécula así
es que date una buena idea de cómo es y
además en este solvente también tenemos
el anillo med occ si este es el método
si me tóxico
entonces queremos pensar en qué tipo de
reacción se va a dar con estas tres
moléculas y bueno para hacer las cosas
un poco más sencillas vamos a pensar
únicamente en los últimos cuatro tipos
de reacciones que hemos visto entonces
ésta podría ser una reacción s/n
s m 1
2 o 1 así es que vamos a fijarnos en
todas las pistas de averiguar cuál de
estas reacciones es la que va a suceder
y vamos a dibujar el mecanismo de la
reacción
entonces nos dieron este solvente y esta
otra cosa en el solvente y lo primero
que vamos a hacer es ver cómo afecta a
este solvente qué pistas nos da y
siempre que tengas una reacción y te
fijes en el solvente lo primero que
tienes que hacer es pensar si es
práctico o no y práctico significa que
hay hidrógenos que se pueden liberar y
flotar libremente en la solución ok que
hay átomos que se pueden quedar con el
electrón del hidrógeno y que el protón
esté flotando libremente y si nos
fijamos en este solvente pues si tenemos
bastantes hidrógenos pero todos esos
hidrógenos están enlazados con algún
carbono y los carbonos muy pocas veces
le van a robar su electrón al hidrógeno
para que el protón del hidrógeno se
quede flotando libremente en la solución
y el carbono no es tan
electro negativo si tuviéramos
hidrógenos enlazados con algún oxígeno
entonces sí sería muy probable que el
oxígeno le robara su electrón al
hidrógeno y que el producto del
hidrógeno se quedará flotando en la
solución haciendo que esa fuera una
solución práctica sin embargo aquí
tenemos puros hidrógenos enlazados con
carbonos los cuales no les roban sus
electrones a los hidrógenos entonces
este es un solvente práctico
frente a práctico
pero chico ahora ya vimos un poco de
esto con las reacciones sn 2 y s n 1
pero la misma idea aplica para tener una
reacción sn 2 o una reacción de 2
necesitas un núcleo filo muy fuerte o
una base muy fuerte y bueno hay
moléculas que son núcleo filos muy
fuertes y base es muy fuerte pero ser un
núcleo filo fuerte o una base fuerte no
son la misma cosa y no están
completamente correlacionadas pero eso
ya lo hemos visto ahora si tuviéramos
una solución práctica en lugar de a
práctica todos esos protones libres de
la solución práctica estabilizarían al
núcleo a filo fuerte o a la base fuerte
aunque hay todos esos protones
reaccionarían con el núcleo filo o con
la base y se llevarían los electrones
extra que tienen los núcleos filos
fuertes y las bases fuertes y entonces
no se podrían dar estas reacciones
para que se dé una reacción sn 2 a 2
necesitas que no haya protones flotando
en tu solución osea necesitas un
solvente práctico así es que los
solventes a prácticos favorecen las
reacciones sn 2
2 pero bueno entonces ya estamos
pensando en que va a ser una reacción s
n 2 o 2 y ahora pues pensemos en los
reactivos tenemos por aquí un millón de
toks y será un núcleo filo fuerte o
débil y bueno el guión me tocó si yo
meto c's y resulta que es un núcleo filo
fuertísimo que es un núcleo filo
cleo y lo fuerte
fuerte y eso nos señala en la dirección
de sm2 porque pues esta molécula es muy
pequeña y puede entrar en cualquier
lugar esta molécula no va a ser impedida
así es que ya tenemos dos puntos a favor
de las reacciones sn 2 pero el meta ok
si también es una base extremadamente
fuerte base extremadamente
mamá
y mente fuerte
fuerte lo cual nos indica que si vamos a
ver reacciones de tipo 2 ahora la última
cosa en la que nos falta pensar es en el
carbono del cual se va a desprender el
grupo saliente si nos fijamos en el
bromo ciclo pentano este tiene
únicamente un grupo funcional que es
este bromo de aquí entonces este es el
grupo saliente y por lo tanto este
carbono de aquí es el carbono alfa y es
un carbono secundario
este carbono que es el carbono alfa
saber carbono alfa carbono alfa
un carbono secundario carbono secundario
con dario y esto de aquí es una pista
muy neutra porque tenemos un carbono
alfa secundario si tuviéramos un carbono
alfa primario o un simple grupo metilo
esto apuntaría mucho más a una reacción
sn 2 para que bueno de hecho si
tuviéramos un solo grupo metilo entonces
definitivamente tendría que ser una
reacción sn 2 porque no se podría formar
un doble enlace por otro lado si el
carbono alfa fuera un carbono terciario
si este carbono estuviera enlazado con
algún otro carbono eso favorecería
reacciones sn 1
1 porque si el carbono alfa fueron
carbono terciario el carbó catión que se
formaría cuando el grupo saliente se
fuera de la molécula sería un kart
bocatín suficientemente estable entonces
en cualquier momento el grupo saliente
se podría ir empezando una reacción s n
1 o 1 pero en este caso tenemos un
carbono secundario eso es muy neutro
cualquiera de estas reacciones podría
suceder pero si nos fijamos en todas las
las pistas tenemos aquí un núcleo filo y
base muy fuerte y una solución a
práctica entonces lo que vamos a tener
es una reacción sn 2 o una reacción de 2
así es que ahora vamos a dibujar los
mecanismos de reacción de estas dos
reacciones y vamos a empezar con la
reacción s n 2 que tenemos aquí bromo
ciclo ventana
esta es la parte del ciclo pantano y
tenemos por aquí un bromo y tenemos a
nuestro núcleo filo med occ si por aquí
me oxy que tiene una carga negativa
tiene 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 electrones de
valencia tiene una carga negativa
uno de estos electrones puede llegar y
atacar al sustrato este carbono de aquí
y en ese mismo momento
simultáneamente el bromo se puede quedar
con este electrón de aquí y entonces lo
que tenemos es un bromo con un electrón
de más o sea que ahora es un bromuro que
antes tenía 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 electrones
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 electrones pero ahora se
quedó con otro electrón entonces tiene
una carga negativa y en lugar de ser
bromo ahora es un anillo bromuro
ahora dibujamos la cadena de carbonos
por aquí y bueno aquí no estamos siendo
muy específicos en cómo dibujamos los
enlaces con los carbonos no estamos
enseñando que ningún carbono salte de la
pantalla ni se vaya al fondo de la
pantalla entonces podríamos dibujar una
estructura que al que sería más fácil de
dibujar pero no bueno entonces aquí este
método si se enlaza con este carbono
tenemos aquí este carbono alfa que se
enlaza con el met oxy ch3 el cual ya no
tiene una carga negativa porque se acaba
de enlazar con este carbono que por
cierto está enlazado implícitamente con
otro hidrógeno por aquí y listo ya
terminamos con la reacción sn 2 y ahora
vamos a dibujar el mecanismo de reacción
de la reacción de 2 pero ahora sí vamos
a tener que dibujar unos hidrógenos así
es que reacción
de tipo
2 que tenemos nuestro ciclo pentanos por
aquí
con sube átomo de bromo y el bromo tiene
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 electrones de valencia
entonces este es el carbono alfa y estos
2 de aquí son los carbonos beta y cada
uno de estos 2 carbonos tienen dos
hidrógenos ok un hidrógeno otro
hidrógeno pero para dibujar en los otros
dos hidrógenos vamos a borrar estas
vetas de aquí
y aquí están los otros dos hidrógenos
ahora estamos en una reacción de tipo 2
aquí en la reacción s n 2 el met toxi
actúa como un muy buen núcleo filo y en
la reacción de tipo es 2 el met ok si es
una muy buena base así es que el med occ
si se va a llevar el protón de alguno de
los hidrógenos de los carbonos beta y
entonces nos ponemos a pensar en cual
hidrógeno se va a llevar el med occ si
pensamos en la regla de sites er pero
los dos carbonos beta tienen la misma
cantidad de hidrógeno así es que cual
protón se lleva el med occ si va a ser
algo aleatorio y de hecho no vamos a
poder notar cuál de los hidrógenos se
llevó porque esta es una molécula
simétrica así es que pues lo vamos a
dibujar así tenemos un oxígeno con su
carga negativa tiene 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
electrones porque tiene una carga
negativa
está enlazado con un grupo metilo y el
met oxy es una muy buena base y entonces
puede tomar uno de sus electrones y
regalárselo al protón del hidrógeno y
entonces el libro que no se va con el
met ox y dejando atrás su electrón el
cual puede pasar con este carbono
formando un doble enlace entre estos dos
carbonos y ahora si el bromo se queda
con este electrón de este carbono y se
sale de la molécula que este bromo es un
muy buen grupo saliente y bueno eso es
algo que tenemos que tomar en cuenta
pero el hecho de que el bromo sea un
buen grupo saliente en realidad favorece
a los cuatro tipos de reacciones pero
bueno este carbono se queda con este
electrón y entonces el bromo se puede
quedar con el electrón del carbono
en un solo paso ya terminamos con la
reacción de dos y eso es lo que
distingue a las reacciones s n 2 y 2 que
todo sucede en un paso y los dos
reactivos los dos reactivos interactúan
en el paso qué determina la velocidad de
la reacción aunque pues en realidad hay
un solo paso y tal cual lo que nos queda
después de que pase esto el an ión med
occ si hace un enlace con el protón de
este hidrógeno entonces por aquí tenemos
un oxígeno con 1 2 3 4 5 6 electrones de
valencia y el electrón extra que tenía
se lo dio al hidrógeno y ahora están
enlazados y tenemos aquí
el grupo metilo y entonces tenemos aquí
una molécula de metanol y este hidrógeno
dejó su electrón en esta molécula que
déjame la dibujo y una vez tenemos aquí
la cadena de carbono y este hidrógeno
dejó su electrón que se fue con el
carbono alfa aunque hay tenemos aquí al
carbono alfa y bueno implícitamente en
cada una de las esquinas de este ciclo
tenemos un carbono
así es que aquí también tenemos un
carbono que este carbono ve aquí y el
hidrógeno le dejó su electrón a este
carbono alfa entonces se forma un enlace
doble entre estos dos carbonos y el
átomo de bromo ya se fue de la molécula
y se quedó con el electrón de este
carbono que por cierto ya lo estaba
abrazando bastante fuerte porque el
bromo es muy electro negativo a grace se
lleva a este electrón de aquí y entonces
tiene una carga negativa y listo ya
terminamos con la reacción de dos y
entonces regresando a la pregunta
original cuál de estas reacciones va a
suceder pues van a suceder ambas
reacciones
la reacción s n 2 y la reacción euros
ambas reacciones al mismo tiempo porque
tenemos todas las condiciones necesarias
como para que sucedan cada una de estas
reacciones entonces vamos a tener ambos
mecanismos
y déjame los separa un poco esta es la
reacción sm2
y esta es la reacción de 2
entonces en cualquier cosa en la que
estés haciendo esta reacción ya sea un
frasco una olla o una caldera en
cualquier cosa en la que estés haciendo
esta reacción vas a obtener ambas
reacciones y por lo tanto también vas a
obtener ambos productos vas a obtener
esto y también esto de aquí